Speaker 1: I cannot tell you how sick of and
disgusted by this new incoming Republican
Congressman George Santos I am. This is the
guy who earlier in the week I told you that
the openly gay Jewish Republican who had been
elected lied about his employment history.
And he lied about his educational
history and he lied that four of
his employees were victims in
the Pulse nightclub shooting
and that it was lie after lie after lie. And then
after that, we learned, okay, well, he lied about
all of those things, but he is Jewish, right? It
appears that he lied about being Jewish as well.
Okay. I said, at least he really is gay. And
I said it jokingly, because of course he is.
And it has now been revealed that three years ago
he was married to a woman. Now you could be gay
and have been married to a woman. We know of
situations that due to stigma or family shame
or for whatever reason, that a member of the LGBT
community might live in a way that is different
than their true feelings. And maybe that's the
case with this guy. But he hid the fact that he
had been married to a woman and divorced her
as recently as just a couple of years ago,
and he lied about everything else. So what
are we to believe? And it is just stunning.
Openly gay Congressman elect George Santos
didn't disclose divorce with woman, writes Roger
Sullenberger for The Daily Beast. Santos ran his
campaign as an openly gay Republican. Since he was
elected, a number of key biographical details have
started to crumble. Here is the latest one. And it
is yet another one of these cases where we find
out that the truth appears to be very different
from the story that he told. As the article reads,
and this is accurate. Santos, who claims he has,
quote, never experienced discrimination in the
Republican Party, broke barriers when he became
the first openly gay non-incumbent Republican
candidate elected to Congress. But according
to court records obtained by The Daily Beast,
Santos appeared to be the subject of a previously
unacknowledged September 2019 divorce almost
September almost 2020, rather, with a woman in
Queens County, New York. The divorce, which
Santos has not discussed publicly, adds new
uncertainty to his already shaky biographical
and political claims. I am openly gay,
have never had an issue with my sexual identity in
the past decade. And I can tell you and assure you
I will always be an advocate for LGBTQ folks.
Now, maybe he's bisexual. He didn't say that.
Maybe there's some other explanation. But when
you've lied about everything, it starts to
become very, very difficult to believe that. We
also have additional new information about the
stories related to his supposed Jewish ancestry.
CNN reporting incoming congressman's claim his
grandparents fled the Holocaust contradicted by
genealogy records. And as I said earlier this
week, it's not stolen valor. We apply that to the
military, but it is taking it is appropriating a
story that includes trauma and oppression and
discrimination that your family did not suffer
and making it your own. And it's disgusting. And
Kozinski wrote for CNN claims by Jorge Santos that
his grandparents, quote, survived the Holocaust
as Ukrainian Jewish refugees from Belgium, who
changed their surname to survive, are contradicted
by sources reviewed by CNN's case file, including
Family Tree is compiled by genealogy websites,
records on Jewish refugees and interviews with
multiple genealogist Santos, who has called
himself half-Jewish and a Latino Jew. Folks,
I'm actually a Latino Jew. OC has claimed his
maternal grandfather was originally from Ukraine
and fled to Brazil to escape Nazism. Sounds
like my family history to Argentina except fake.
In another telling, the New York Republican said
his grandparents converted to Catholicism during
the rise of Nazism in Belgium after fleeing
Stalin. In another telling, he claimed his
family changed their name to survive Nazi
ism. Anyway, no proof of those claims. It
all appears to be completely and totally made
up. So. There's a lot of important things here.
I don't want to discount the possibility that for
whatever reason it happens that gay people marry,
they get in a heterosexual marriage. And there's
all sorts of different reasons. And if that's
what happened. But he lied about everything else,
well, then we can still talk about all those other
things. But this guy, it's hard to find a more
dishonest person than George Santos based on what
we've seen and learned so far. And so I believe
everything has to be under the microscope. Now,
does it matter? He was voted by the people to
become a congressman, and he is congressman
elect. As I said earlier this week. In any
normal job, not a job where you're elected,
you would be fired for misstating so much about
your history now. You wouldn't declare your sexual
orientation as part of a normal job interview. So
that's kind of off the table. I don't know that
if you tell your employer you're Jewish and you're
not. I don't know about that having consequences.
But your resumé, where you worked, where you got
your your degree. These are things where if it
turned out you falsified it, you would be fired
essentially in just about every job. And so what
happens next? What happens next with this guy?
Probably nothing, quite frankly, but a disgusting
turn of events. And what started with he may have
misstated or exaggerated his work history and his
role as what was it like an asset manager or
something? It seems his entire background is
completely and totally fake. I'm going to now
take another step back. It does seem this guy
is from the species Homo sapiens. That appears
to be true. He claims to be human. He presents
as human. I believe he is actually human. Maybe
that's the next thing that will be proven wrong